des équipes solliciter plus que
d'habitude et pour cause les cabinets
médicaux ferment et le quidam se tourner
d'abord vers la maison médicale est
selon la gravité de la prise en charge
vers le samu et des urgences
les quatre maisons médicales du
territoire s'organisent pour les jours
gras comme pour un week end ou des jours
fériés
un accueil possible dès 7 heures jusqu'à
23 heures avec deux médecins qui régule
les appelle donc on répond à l'urgence
aux gens qui nous appellent parce que
les mets sont absents parce qu'ils ont
des problématiques qui vous agirez
rapidement et donc les maisons médicales
de gains sont ouvertes mais saint paul
la meynard trinité marins sont ouverts à
côté de ces médecins d'autres équipes
réceptionne également de nombreux appels
pour le samu il y a en cette période
moins de problèmes médicaux et un
constat alarmant une multiplication des
affections traumatologique
on a vraiment l'impression que les gens
bois les quantités industrielles
l'alcool qui conduisent n'importe
comment que ce sont deux roues en
voiture et on a un nom d'augmentation
l'accident qui est assez impression ça
fait 12 ans que je suis là et si vrai
que j'ai fait le week-end dernier au
samu et je me suis dis donc on
intervention j'avais jamais vu autant
d'accidents graves de la route que le
week-end dernier
et là on est reparti pour faire la même
chose et le problème c'est que ces
gens-là ils arrivent après aux urgences
et donc ils vont sur chargé des urgences
le samu dispose de deux équipes
d'intervention pour tout le territoire
des équipes vite débordé y compris aux
urgences depuis quinze jours le constat
est sans appel il y a deux à trois
accidents de moto par jour se pose la
question de la responsabilité
individuelle